beyond his supporters
behind the fence of the walter reed
medical center the president's condition
was in question after a day of
contradictions yesterday
he tweeted a medical bulletin himself
last night
on the therapeutic miracles of his
treatment
if you look at the therapeutics which
i'm taking right now
some of them and others are coming out
soon that are looking like
frankly they're miracles if you want to
know the truth they're miracles people
criticize me when i say that
but we have things happening that look
like they're miracles coming down from
god
donald trump seemed like he said to be
feeling good
but questions do persist about a day
when his doctors first contradicted
then agreed with the white house on the
assessment of the president's condition
and the timing of his diagnosis
the medical team gave a timeline that
suggested his hospital airlift
had come 72 hours after he was found to
be infected
and 48 hours after he'd been given
treatment
but yesterday that story and his precise
timings
changed the white house has since given
a clarification
of what the doctors had to say it speaks
not of 72 hours since diagnosis but of
three days
not of 48 hours since treatment but of
two days it presents a timing less
precise than that given
by the medical team and provides room
for maneuver within the timeline
following the white house statement the
president's doctor issued one of his own
correcting himself he spoke of day three
and day two in line with the white house
version
what he'd said first could have meant
the president was in full
and active campaign mode whilst
knowingly infected
this was him in minnesota on wednesday
evening the next day he was at events in
new jersey
the contact tracing effort around the
president reads like a who's who of the
washington establishment
who's positive and who's not last
weekend he announced
his supreme court nominee amy coney
barrett in a white house ceremony
at least seven attendees here have since
tested positive
the rose garden event has the air now of
a social gathering
come super spreader this weekend saw a
rally of trump supporters in the center
of the u.s capitol
the plight of the president it seemed
hadn't changed minds on covert
precautions
the reason i don't wear a mask is i
think it's my personal responsibility
to keep myself with a good immunity
there is no scientific hardcore evidence
that says that those little molecules
aren't getting through your mask
while the president remains in hospital
his democratic opponents have pulled
negative advertising for the time being
otherwise full campaigning for them
continues
not for donald trump for him for now
there's more to life than politics james
matthews
sky news washington